well for more analysis on the New
Hampshire primary I'm not joined by
Jocelyn sage Mitchell who is an
assistant professor teaching comparative
and American politics at Northwestern
University here in cata thank you so
much for coming in so a big night for
Bernie Sanders but Pete's Buzzi judge
not far from him and Amy Klobuchar doing
quite well as well what does this result
say about what is on voters minds the
Democratic primary voters minds as they
head towards November great thanks for
having me you're absolutely right that
this was a big night for Sanders Buddha
judge and Klobuchar but really the big
story is Amy Klobuchar for a candidate
that was consistently polling in the
single digits to come with almost 20% of
the actual primary vote is massive in
the debate last third last Friday she
called for empathy and experience in the
White House and asked the voters of New
Hampshire to take a chance on her and
they did and this really makes her a
viable candidate going forward in this
process which voters have shifted
towards her precisely well some of the
oxidized right some of the exit polling
do show that those white
college-educated women who had
previously been supporting Elizabeth
Warren may have shifted towards Amy
Klobuchar right of course there's still
a long way to go until November still a
lot of states coming up next is Nevada
and South Carolina and I think all eyes
there will be on the minorities votes
african-americans especially in South
Carolina who are they likely to turn
towards excellent question I mean you
know Nevada is really important so is
South Carolina because now we introduce
further diversity to this primary
process we've heard about the voter
mindsets in Iowa Midwest New Hampshire
Northeast but now we move to the west
and the south and as you said we bring
in Latinos in Nevada and
african-americans in in South Carolina
and these are very important
constituencies of the Democratic Party
it's important what they think these are
big tests for putas judge and Amy
Klobuchar because they have to show that
they have appeal beyond their largely
white Midwest demographics I also a big
test for Joe Biden right there
disappointing first two results for him
he's pinning all his hopes on the strong
support that he enjoys with the
african-american community in South
Carolina right but you know what two
weeks is a long time to wait so if he
doesn't do well in South Carolina do you
think that will be the end for him to be
honest I think he needs an experience he
needs to do well in Nevada to have a
chance because I'm not entirely sure
that the african-american voters are
going to wait around for a candidate
that they no longer see is viable or
what about Michael Bloomberg of course
he didn't take part in in the New
Hampshire primary and he's actually not
faced voters just yet
is he a plausible candidates for the
Democrats even that is that is the
million-dollar question right now he's
got a lot of my should say
billion-dollar money we don't know
because he hasn't been any ballots yet
and he's not going to be until Super
Tuesday which is March 3rd this is his
strategy to avoid these four early
states to go for the Super Tuesday
states where 14 states will will will go
to the polls
he's been saturating the airwaves and he
has been polling pretty well in
California for example but this strategy
might backfire because some candidates
as we saw Amy Klobuchar and others are
getting serious momentum from these
early candidates so what will happen in
march 3rd we just have to wait and see
all right Jostein what do you think see
things heading over the next few months
I mean can Bernie Sanders if he's the
nominee beat Donald Trump in November
Sanders is of course a Democratic
Socialist with a progressive agenda is
America ready for that another great
question I think that it's very telling
that at every democratic debate the
candidates have taken pains to express
that no matter what they are going to be
unified behind each other and to be
honest no matter who ends up being the
nominee they're gonna need that unified
front all the other candidates and their
supporters are going to have to get
behind them it's hard to beat an
incumbent president
all right jocelyn sage makes you very
interesting to get your thoughts on this
thank you very much for joining us on
lodges here